yo man bootleg cab show special guest
here
the homie
i was gonna call you annie bro andy
mineo is here what's up bro he said my
last name right so i got big respect i'm
telling man yeah how often do you get
like maneo or oh it's butchered every
time
what is like the most annoying
pronunciation for you like when people
get it wrong uh mineo because it sounds
like mayonnaise so you know that's the
one i'm like i no respect no respect no
respect at this point i don't even care
it's crazy because in in one of my
one of my bigger records that that went
gold i say it in the record i'm like
it's mineo say it with me mineo okay
great
uh
so
you know they're like i'm a huge fan man
mineo i'm like you've never heard a song
in your life because you would have at
least heard that record i'm happy to
hear to hear that you like my song that
went viral on tick tock yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right i'm happy to
hear you like coming in hot that's right
that's right huge fan huge [ __ ] fan
um
yo so yeah of course of course yeah
we're giving everyone free pubs yeah big
shout out to mountain i mean go get a
check ghost energy needs to cut the
check um
so has this been your first time hitting
the road since
the world yeah vince the old panty
this is uh you know we actually had a
whole this funny look on the back of
this
this is like the tour merch
that was all the cities we were supposed
to hit right but it wasn't that it was
only like what like eight or something
right or ten right now we're only doing
nine cities right but on the you know we
had these press before the whole thing
shifted gear but we were gonna do 24
cities or something like that
i had a whole band um
and basically what happened is uh
when we started figuring out what was
going on with the mandates what was also
happening with like if anybody gets sick
what you have to deal with right we were
like yo we can't take this risk because
financially you could just sink yourself
so
had a full band
um and if one person gets sick
you can't put them on the bus you can't
fly them home you have to leave them in
that city
for 10 days pay for their hotels
pay them pay them their per diem fly
someone new in the same day have them
learn all the parts and then pay them so
now you're paying double triple and
that's only if one person gets sick so
imagine if three people get right and
then you know that's gonna happen right
somebody get exposed
so we was like yo we can't be out here
paying for
30 hotel you know nights and and doing
so it just didn't make sense so we just
shrunk the show down
we uh limited our exposure down to like
17 days on the road instead of 40. right
so if anyone gets sick by the time you
know we find out hopefully they can be
home to quarantine but everyone's good
so far damn yeah
it's weird man it's a weird time even
the tour too so i was gonna say like i
know like uh
you know uh the homies uh chris webby
and uh dizzy and futuristic at a tour
that they just canceled because uh
that's right of all the all the [ __ ]
that was going on and they didn't want
to deal with the mandates right chris
was like yo i'm not gonna make nobody
who's my fan
get mandy vac see i'm saying so it's
weird are you vaccinated
i am yep yeah you and me both we're both
jabbed up yeah i got the uh what do i
got pfizer yeah me too fizer poppies in
the building yeah my dog got the uh
johnson and johnson how's he doing is
your life he's like i'm barely back
yo the johnson johnson just sounded good
because it was like so it's just one and
done
yeah and then everyone and then you grow
you know a third eye so that's what it
is you know it's crazy though because we
were talking like how
the the mandate [ __ ] man i just feel
like we're just living in a very weird
time you were saying how like some of
your california shows that usually would
sell out aren't selling how they usually
would because a lot of your fans are
not wanting to
adhere to some of the local policies as
far as vaccinations et cetera and a lot
of people moved
so like you know i was saying i was
hitting my community people moved the
[ __ ] out of people like cali yeah they
just like oh i don't even live there no
more bro i'm gone so this is the
strangest selling
but what's crazy is the rest of the tour
has been selling fine in the southern
states in florida and texas all that so
it's like i'm like oh i think it might
just be cali on lockdown still um but i
don't know
who knows man it's just very strange no
it is man i feel like we look like like
i just every day some new [ __ ] happens
or i'm like are we [ __ ] living in a
simulation yeah bro the world has really
changed
and like they're firing nurses out here
for not getting vaccinated and they were
working during the pandemic what the
[ __ ] is going on
now why do nurses also not want to give
back so i'm like there's so many there's
just so many angles it's like what is
happening yeah like why are the like
yeah it's just it's it's crazy bro i
don't know man boy our boy kyrie not
gonna be able to play in new york
and we're psychotic you know what's wild
is i i don't know if this is true but i
saw on twitter someone had said that um
michael porter jr
is gonna be able to play in new york and
he's not getting vaccinated so when he
comes to new york he's gonna be able to
play but they won't let kyrie play
which would be kind of wild
maybe because he's
i don't know maybe because new york pays
him it's what you know maybe you when i
go to different states i'm going to play
different taxes for merch that i sell
that might make sense because he's all
his tax money's coming through new york
maybe
maybe the kyrie [ __ ] is crazy though it
is wild
shout out mpj
i did a little mpj freestyle
he's gonna pop out on denver next week
oh really yeah he's a homie man michael
porter jr popping out at the show yeah
he's gonna pop out under the next
unvaxxed at a show
might have to
you might be the reason why the nuggets
uh
have a breakout he's not coming edit
that out he's not coming to the show
it's going to be kind of fire if you had
him pull up though
yeah i mean he's on my fantasy
basketball team so okay perfect i hope
oh you got him yeah i got him too yeah i
think a lot of people let him slip
because they were like he's not vaxxed
i'm like [ __ ] that
oh yeah yeah okay run me mpj baby i need
to have a breakout year and it could
definitely hurt your fantasy if you get
if you go out for a week
you know what's crazy about it
when i was talking with mpj we did like
a i did a freestyle before the album
came out
mpj freestyle so he jumped on alive with
me he was talking a little bit and he
said when he he actually got covered
right before the bubble
and what happens is after you get
covered it could take
like months for you to get a negative
test right so those antibodies are
hanging around exactly just hanging so
he was like yo i almost couldn't play in
the bubble because even though i had it
a month before i couldn't produce a
negative test
and so it just you have to have to get
test every single day until you finally
get that green light but that's i mean
i was gonna do some overseas travel this
year and i got covered and i couldn't
reproduce a negative test and so we were
just like
i can't go to italy and then
be stuck over there are you are you
italian yeah yeah okay okay yeah yeah so
i'm like i can't go over there are you
italian no no i'm i'm i'm just a lot of
caucasians east eastern europe german
irish russian
just uh the kid's a heinz wiser he's got
blue eyes that's what it is
yeah he's what it is um nah
what what was uh you're just a fan of uh
michael porter junior like how did like
like yeah he came out to a few of the
shows a couple years ago uh as he was
getting ready to go to the league and we
would just kick it wouldn't be in denver
and then um
i had a line
in
this just like freestyle i was writing
i was like it's a lot of merry men in
the nba got shorties in cities on ndas
log keep your hand on mpj that he gonna
keep his pants on and behave i was just
like i like that it's like oh i should
just call it mpj freestyle so
i did and then he just happened to be
the homie so it was like
yo i named a song after you he's like
all right you know he promoted it jumped
on ig live but
yeah it kind of just happened that way
you're obviously a big basketball guy
are you are you a knicks fan or what's
your team
this is strange i'm actually
none of them none of my teams are from
new york even though i'm from new york
right i'm a utah jazz fan are you mormon
yes 100 mormon
me and my 17 wives no shout out to the
mormons out there choose the right yeah
um
nah i just i grew up stocked in malone
that's an interesting uh porno sack
you know what always it was to be a kid
growing up the same time we grew up and
to be like you know what horna sacks
stockton those are my guys you know yeah
yeah you got jordan duncan yeah right
right right right yeah you know what it
was it was just like one
i liked their jerseys the utah jazz like
the jerseys were fired and he had music
notes and all right and then it was just
like seeing these unassuming
uh high shorts white dude balling out i
was just like wow
i have a chance yeah i have a chance
like maybe i can make the league
so seeing stockton it was always so
funny um i hear these stories about john
stockton that would just make me crack
up so like
gary payton
would try to like get in stockton's head
right
and he's like uh he's like i banged your
mom last night on the court and stockton
would just be like she's a great lady
just run up the yo like
just wouldn't let people into his psyche
is a great light and he's like i'm gonna
shove a banana up here and he's like
tons of protein no tons of potassium and
just run up the car i'm like yo this
dude is just and then he would walk
around
for the uh
uh the olympics and no one would bother
him i'm just like an unassuming no he
always would have his little collared
shirt on yeah just balling out i just
always thought that was so funny so so
you're a jazz fan that's like your
number one team
yeah i mean but i'm gonna keep it a buck
like i don't follow that are you more of
a okay okay i'm saying it's just like
i'll catch a game here and there
but it's kind of that's my childhood
team and and so i stick with that it's
like green bay packers on my football
team but it
had to do with like
favre the lambo leap
cheese on your head
it was like i was watching a game with
my sister when i was a kid and they did
the lambo leap i was like why they why
are they jumping in the crowd she's like
that's what they do at lambo i was like
it's like a stage dive right right right
right i was like why they got cheese on
their heads like they produce a lot of
ch i was like that's it that's my i mean
you're just gonna have a square on it
like that's so crazy to be right so
hey shout out to the packers and uh and
to uh the the jazz of utah
that's it yeah shout out them like yeah
pirates cause i like their logo so randy
weird kid how was uh you do you go to
utah on tour
no we got an off day coming up on our
way to denver so take some time stop in
stop into salt lake
say what's up to some of the uh the the
mormon homies
homies and their absolutely wives uh
yeah we're gonna try to get off day i
mean they're all gonna get their own
planets by the way too
when they die is that in the contract i
grew up i grew up in mesa arizona which
is the second largest mormon population
in the world so yeah it's pretty wild
yeah where do you land on religion stuff
these days i'm an atheist atheist yeah
you're you're like can okay i just want
to ask you because i hear people call
you a christian rapper
and i listen to your music and
obviously there's like
like stuff in there that's like
godly right like lines but it's not like
i don't look at you that way i just look
at you as like a rapper who happens to
be a christian
as opposed to being like a because you
know when i grew up man christian rap
was corny as [ __ ] yeah yeah and um
i feel like lecrae was like the first
guy to come along to be like oh no he's
just dope he can rap yeah but he also
you know is obviously like how do you do
you consider yourself like quote unquote
christian rapper or is that something
that you embrace well for
it's an interesting combo because for
years i've just tried to like
just be like yo can i just be a rapper
and be a part of the community because i
always felt like in some way in hip-hop
to be called
something before your title
like a female rapper a gay whatever a
christian a mother so you know gender
orientation or religion anything those
that precede a title it always feels
like it marginalizes like right away
people already have yeah so it's like oh
she's that's a female rapper right right
you know it's all those things so
i tried to just be like man i
i feel like i'm just a part of hip-hop
but i am a christian so i would never
deny being a christian right just be
like
that title
it's a weird it's a weird conversation
because people be like oh yeah we'll
play you on sunday then you know on the
radio you're like
i took a meeting one time
one of my albums the first neverland it
was like doing really well on the charts
i took a meeting at this is 50 and 50
cent was there and so i walked by him i
was like yo what's up man he's like
lifting weights
and uh he was like you know didn't give
me no time he was like yeah yeah what up
and then his man was like yo he got the
number one album on itunes right now and
then he was like oh word come into my
office right so i ended up hanging out
with 50 for like two hours random i'm
like
i looked at my manager i was like yo i'm
gonna go on the off yeah
and i went in he just started asking me
questions because you know at that time
like he's just a smart dude he wants to
learn so he's like you got a number one
album like what's going on
starts asking me all these questions i
start telling about this i'm like yo
when i first started like
you know
10 years plus years ago i had some very
explicitly christian bars i was juiced
up about my relationship with jesus ah
you know so i think that's where that um
initial thing comes from you know i'm
saying that a lot of my core fans uh
share those same ideas right so
you get that but over the years just my
sound my view the way i approach things
has evolved and
so
anyways when i was talking with him he
was like yeah bro people are gonna try
to if you continue
basically like if people continue to see
you that way and just not a part of
hip-hop they're gonna try to marginalize
you to the
gospel hour on sunday or something you
know i said i was like oh man
that was never my intention but at the
end of the day i've just let go of
trying to control that
narrative to a degree because it's like
you're just gonna do you and like let
people feel how they feel that's it man
at the end of the day you can't really
control it and
it's also it's like when you tell people
hey man i i don't really call myself
that then that becomes the the headline
of the interview
and it just it's a circle you know i'm
saying so i'm like whatever y'all want
to call is the music dope
i always like like i think like you know
if you think of kanye when he first came
out like
you know outside his mixtape [ __ ] but
you know if we think of jesus walks like
yeah jesus like people didn't look at
kanye as like a christian rapper they
just looked at him and was like oh [ __ ]
this is a rapper that's
did a song about jesus this is different
and it was hard because i think up until
that song
any songs about god and like hip hop
were always like i remember you know i
grew up around a bunch of hardcore
christians
that used to have channel 21 on in
phoenix which was like the christian
channel
and it would be the whackest [ __ ]
music really oh my god there was some
guy named um damn it what was the guy's
name carmen
i don't know there was this dude oh my
god that's like do you know what i'm
talking about
i do
and then kirk franklin obviously was
like you know who kind of crossed over a
bit yeah he did gospel and then he had
some he put some rap stuff in there yeah
like what's it i i was gonna ask you
like um for you like
do you
would you collab like like
do you kind of watch who you collaborate
with if they don't kind of align with
like where you are well yeah i think
like as just a as a man with principles
like
i want to create the way i want to
create art is i have some brand filters
for myself i always want to make things
that i think are
incredibly dope artistically excellent
but i also want things that are
wholesome you know what i'm saying so
like you don't cuss in your music right
no i don't
um
i saw music as like a dividing
something that like divided me and my my
family and at a certain point in time
you know i'd get in the car my cannabis
cd would be broken in half or whatever
you know what i'm saying so my mom just
was like nah you can't play she just
didn't you know when you're 14.
she didn't appreciate getting [ __ ]
yeah she didn't she did
um
but now it's right song by the way it is
it's it's not pc anymore right and word
nomentry
yes
second round ko um
so yeah but now it's cool to see the
music that i make is able to bring
people together i see like at a show
a guy will be there and he'll bring his
son he's like this is my 12 year old son
it's his first concert ever and we get
to come do this together you know that's
fine oh that's crazy so yeah when i go
to do collaborations like i've done
you know
i've i've had collaborations with people
from all different walks of life and
world views um but we just try to make
sure that when we create something we
create something that your family we
align with yes i'm saying like there's
middle ground there's there's stuff we
can create so
fonte just jumped on the record and we
did something that was great
so yeah little brother man one of the
greatest i just had a conversation with
uh
luke from dreamville about because his
manager's big poo
so oh my gosh yeah he moved into
management yeah so he's got little
brother on his album the dreamville
album just came out gold mouth and i was
like
he's from north carolina i was like
you realize how big of a deal that is
he's like bro honestly i didn't really
even [ __ ] know about little brother
until like six years ago and then i
started working with pooh you know yeah
he really ended like tapped into the
music but little brother yeah fonte
how'd you link up with fonte i just hit
him on twitter you're just a fan right
yeah i was just working on um
this last project and i was like
uh oh fonte would sound crazy on this
actually dell my manager was like
i think he'd sound right i was like oh
yeah
just shoot my shot most of like a lot of
the connection to the relationship has
just been that and then you find out
somehow that they're a fan and they
listen
like me and john bellian connected off
of twitter just like years ago great
livestream yo man i love your stuff
yo i love you know i love your stuff
let's link up start playing basketball
now
you know so it's just yeah
you never know who's really listening or
or you know who's and at the moment
you're you're independent right
no so i just finished my deal um with
reach records
and basically it's just like
we got to renegotiate terms so at the
moment you're like a free agent at
technically technically i mean the album
came out like two weeks ago so i haven't
you know and then i went straight on
tour so i haven't even sat down to sort
through any of that yet but
i guess technically you could say that
yeah we're gonna figure everything out
yeah yo it's crazy because when you have
a record like coming in hot which is
like um
how long after the song came out did it
like really start to pick up
on like tick tock because i felt like it
wasn't right away right right well
amongst our my core fan base like it did
really well
and then it was 2018
i i did it to go on tour me and la craig
went on tour
did it when on tour uh it did great and
then it died off for a second and then
um
steph curry started using it and then it
got used in like a under armour
commercial or something like that
then they went to the finals then the
finals used it so then they had another
pick up then it died down
then will smith used it to announce that
he was on tick-tock
and then it has a moment so it just has
all these waves of light influencers and
then kim kardashian posts with it then
it has another uptick and
that's the thing we live in an era of
landmines not rocket ships you know what
i'm saying so it's like a record could
be sitting around and someone stumbles
on it uses it oh it's crazy it's crazy
yeah
you know songs from like 2014 going
crazy you're like yeah i was thinking
like that the wiz and ty dolla sign song
something new was like
what was that like 2017 and then like
2020 went crazy just went crazy off of a
like it's it's wild yeah and you got a
plaque off that record right yeah we
just got a another goal
it's tight man i mean for being it's an
independent label and no radio play to
be able to have a couple plaques you
know from what we do that's huge man
it's dope man it's really shout out to
the the fans who support us like they
come out for real you know no it's
that's uh i think
i know how hard it is to get a [ __ ]
plaque yeah yeah
especially
on an independent label you know what
i'm saying you know we don't we don't um
yeah like we've never
ever played radio ever yeah i was gonna
ask did you guys ever consider like
bringing on someone to help you work
that record
to radio um well so at the at the time
lecrae
up did like an up deal with colombia so
he did the records with ty dolla signing
all that they did i remember radio with
that
um
so at the time he was with them and uh
i think that was something that was in
consideration is like upcycling through
them so that they could run it
but basically from what i understand
it's like nobody wants to put their neck
on the line at the label
for
a record
because if it doesn't work then it
basically cost them their job so
i just don't think there was enough
people that believed in it to to push
the book i think like i think that
record could like i think that out
astronaut the ocean song was like top
ten at radio
and it was just
not as tight as your song
it was like a very novel novelty like
tick tock record yeah but that was like
crazy yeah crazy
and yeah absolutely what's dope about
what you're doing is like you got you
had one of those but like you have
you could tour
you have like for sure for sure a
built-in like real following right
because we've been at it you know before
that record and so and i've had plaques
before that so it's like
you know we we've proven that we do this
you know what i'm saying hey what up man
we got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics song
right now go get those they got the
socks wwe joints you know i'm saying
shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxoficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksoficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview i i saw on youtube uh is it
your are you you're married yep okay so
i saw you and your wife were talking
about the your real estate investments
and what you guys do in the real estate
yeah yeah yeah so kind of shed some
light on that because the real estate
world right now it's crazy everything's
super
high yeah
so we've been in new york city for the
last 13 years i grew up in syracuse
upstate new york then i went to new york
city and then um we just right before
the pandemic we moved down to atlanta
the label was down there um
cost of living cost of living was
quality of life everything you know it
was just like i'm out i couldn't do
another new york winner bro i was just
my my triple fat goose had seen enough
yeah so i uh we went down there and we
bought our first property and we just
the
the agent we connected uh jay rich he
just like he knows all of atlanta and he
ends up being a friend and a fan and all
that
so he's just been kind of steering us
and we started investing in this
neighborhood that's just going crazy and
um so we just this past week we picked
up our fourth property
in two years
i was on we were on tour and i had to
like stop off at a notary and sign and
uh it's funny man because like that same
day i had a friend pop out
um
he's from syracuse he lived in orlando
he popped out ox and he was like yo when
you gonna when are you gonna pop out
with something you just like when you go
post something out like let your nuts
say you don't say like get a chain get a
car i was like nah get home property i'm
i'm buying real estate yeah he was like
oh you know it is funny i was like dang
i really don't i really don't
pulling out the flex we just kind of
investing in what the the future looks
like for us because in my mind you know
this game of music is very similar to
sports it's like
you can have like a little window where
you can go crazy and then after that
people are like what's new what's next
100
so it's dope that i've been able to
continue to do what i do and and
have a fan base and stuff still keeps
growing but
i just kind of want to plan for if i
ever want to not have to go on tour or
you know what i'm saying say yes to
shows i don't want to no i mean look
there's artists
whose lifeline is literally touring you
know like like it's it's it's um without
the live shows like that's that's what
they depend on to pay their bills that's
right
some rap to pay the bill yeah i i don't
i don't want to be in that position and
i want to have kids eventually you know
i'm saying me and my wife and we like
man i just don't want to be running
around like this you know i'm saying i
think like there's like independent
rappers without saying names but like
they tour all year long
every year it's a tour
and it's like they're dope incredible
artists but it's like [ __ ] like yeah 55
dates every year
like half of your life is on the road
that's right that's right
it's like i couldn't imagine doing that
yeah
yeah it just depends on what you value
you know i'm saying so like for me time
is the biggest thing so if i can invest
in real estate our game plan is to
basically have enough properties that
generate passive income for us that
anything music related is just extra and
so it's like the lifestyle is paid for
we got time back we can do what we want
and um
you know i think that's going to be the
next phase is
you're just you're just like having like
um
tenants or are you doing the airbnb
thing or yeah so we did airbnb for a
little bit and then the pandemic hit so
then it was like i know i was at an old
body i was at an airbnb in atlanta for
sure for like a week really yeah in
january it was called [ __ ] yeah we had
we had everybody running and it started
to pick up was going great and then the
pandemic hit nobody was traveling so
then we had to turn it into long form
rental or whatever and so that's been
the game plan man just like rentals
right now because the mortgage is paid
it cash flows you know so that's for
those watching cash flow is
anything over which what your what your
cost is what your cost is and so
the goal for us is just
have that
right now the interest rate is killer
right so very very good interest rate so
it helps with your cash flow because
your your payment's going to be less
yeah absolutely
yeah man i we just invested man i was
gonna say any advice you'd give for
someone who's watching this that wants
to get into the real estate [ __ ] because
i do feel like it's like a weird time
where
the properties cost more than ever but
the interest rates are lower than ever
so it's like it's like uh do i get it
now do i wait
man i could talk about real estate stuff
forever but basically i would start with
reading books um there's this uh
platform called bigger pockets my wife
loves it she goes on there basically um
anything you can think of like any topic
they've tackled it they've done books on
it they've done podcasts all that uh
that's a great start for me i just
started with rich dad poor dad which was
like shout out to yeah right leverage
dad poor dad i was yeah i read that [ __ ]
in high school yeah it was just a change
in my mindset it helped me understand
what the difference between assets and
liabilities were right like cars even
though they're dope they're depreciating
liabilities they cost you money
everybody where assets are things that
grow in value so i make a song i put it
out right it's while i'm sleeping it's
generating money while i'm sleeping my
car is costing me money right because
it's going down
so um trying to figure out how to
develop more assets which is one of the
reasons we moved start buying property
start investing in things that will grow
um so that was like a starter kit for my
mentality then it was you know other
books and so i would say start there too
um
for real estate stuff it's like this my
my wife has a really good um example she
says
if you want to buy property there's
basically a scale of comfort and
cost
so if the more willing you are to be
uncomfortable the better the price right
so that's the sliding scale and so
you're like oh i want to get a really
well-priced you know
property it's like all right you might
be in the hood for three years you know
what i'm saying or you're like no i want
to live in the best of my eyes you might
be in a small spot that's right or at a
small spot or whatever it is so you have
to weigh that out and for me and my wife
it was like yo
we down we down to thug it out for a
couple years and really just like put
our head down and buy property and you
know not
you know
not ball out you know i'm saying so
we did that and it's been incredible for
us so
that sliding scale will help you
determine what you want to do two is
like if you can if you know how to rehab
or like fix these joints up or you have
people you know contractors that's
really the the end is you got to buy a
crappy property and fix it fix it up and
that's how you get good prices and
that's how you add value fire you know
and you gotta be ready to go it's like
when deals come across the table you're
gonna have better hey how's your guys's
credit scores fire it's perfect perfect
crazy i got like over 800 or something
how like was that something that's been
consistent for you or did you like have
to handle some [ __ ] to get it up to that
ah bro you know what i'm i'm weird but i
just been good with money like since i
was young so when i was in my 20s i was
i was doing these shows i was
selling merch online doing just kind of
entrepreneurial
and um
i had like i'd take the money i'd make i
pull up these spreadsheets on on google
and i'd be like this money i'm gonna
give here this is for saving i even
created a marriage account
when i was single
it's crazy i take a little slice of
every check and i just like put
something in there i'm gonna have to get
married one day because i was like one
day i want to get married and i don't
want to go in here like very very
expensive or a ring or whatever and i
was just like yo i don't want to be
i don't want to be out here like oh now
that i'm ready to go
so you're a single man just budgeting
[ __ ] out on google spreadsheets crazy i
don't even know where this came from bro
i just was a responsible young man so by
the time i met the girl i was ready to
get married i was like oh i got 20 grand
saved so i can go get this ring or
whatever i need to do i was just ready
to go you're a [ __ ] special guy man
weird yeah very strange but you know it
served me well
not for sure why do you think it is like
that what you're doing and the success
you've had somehow flies under the radar
in hip-hop because i think of like
people like russ or even like a guy like
tech nine who's had a lot of independent
success that like
like at one point in time has gotten a
lot of acknowledgement by like
the gatekeepers the hip whatever the
[ __ ] right the curators or whatever you
want to call them peacemakers somehow
you're still kind of flying under the
radar a bit as far as like the amount of
success you've had the touring you're
able to do
the riaa certifications you have right
like do you feel like you're kind of
like what do you why what do you
attribute to that yeah well you know i
and my mentality is like
the first thing i'm gonna start with is
it's me right like i'm gonna take
responsibility because i don't like the
i could blame it on other people i want
to be like all right maybe i just
haven't
made the records you know i'm saying i
made the hits like so i need to keep my
my my pen sharp my craft tight and keep
like my foot on the gas
um but i feel like
it's not a matter of skill it's a matter
of like maybe i just have been
unrecognized you know what i'm saying
and like my time will either come or
i'll just have gone unrecognized but it
doesn't mean that the talent isn't well
it also doesn't mean you ain't [ __ ]
making a lot of money sure sure yeah so
you know there's that um but you know
sometimes i wonder i ask myself these
things i was like oh dude
you know is it a cosign thing like do
you need just somebody
crazy be like that's the one or
do you need just more records uh you
know do you need different
infrastructure
i don't know um those are all the things
that's that's why they call it the game
right like it is a game you got to
figure out how to do this um i think
right now um attention is kind of a
currency and
i don't think i'm very good for tv
because you know i like i don't start
beef with nobody you know i don't be out
here talking crazy i'm just like making
good music but
um
we're trying to figure out you know how
to move next like to make sure that we
get the the recognition i think the
music deserves but i don't know what do
you think i don't know man i think that
um
i mean i do think that the christian
rapper [ __ ] has probably something to do
with it just that being like that's yeah
that's the things people lead with then
they're like oh that ain't from me like
shout out to our good friend emilia
rojas like when he texts me about you
he's like
well he sent me a voice note
so
i hate those people by the way they're
like this is gonna take up my whole
phone 45 [ __ ] second long yo kevin
yo yo he's a christian i'm my guy i know
who he is bro i i dm'd you earlier this
year i don't know if you saw it really
yeah i hit you like yeah when you come
into la i think i hit you in like
february this year
check your dm's buddy who knew all right
okay but anyway
um but no i think that for whatever
reason like that is like a weird like
like you said man anytime you have that
like
thing before rapper yeah right it's like
it it just people already have their
mind made up yeah
and for whatever reason i also think
like well if you want to give it a
chance like if someone told me right now
and like this is just an example like yo
check out this muslim rapper right i'd
be like oh word i'll get to it you know
like it wouldn't be i wouldn't be like
jumping on it if somebody's like yo this
kid's dope check them out because i'd
think like and nothing against muslims
at all it's just like oh i'm that's not
the first thing i'm gonna connect with
right and i think that's kind of the
same thing right but there's mad muslim
rappers right
like everybody so you like
if you didn't lead with that maybe it
would have yeah i think that i think
that that's something because like i
also think too like just the whole
for whatever reason
i don't know man you know do you feel
like being a christian has become like
um
when i grew up i felt like being
religious and being godly was like in
does that make sense
like it was like
what made you think that or maybe
because this is who i grew up around i
grew up around you know my best friend
ramses like his whole family was like a
hardcore christian so like maybe like in
my head like that was like
more widely accepted as to where i feel
like today like
being like super religious people like
and i'm not saying i feel this way but i
just mean in general like i don't think
it's like commercially as accepted as it
used to be do you feel that that's the
case i don't know i almost feel like the
opposite
i don't know like
because when i look at
i don't know when i look at artists
right now like so many of them are
blatantly and openly christian so kanye
justin bieber
you know i'm saying like you hear i mean
dmx even growing up was always like
doing but he was saying he was doing the
prayers yeah right he was doing the
prayer
then he was talking about [ __ ] the
dead body as well yeah yeah on the same
album on the same album
uh he's got blood on his dick because he
[ __ ] the course yeah i'm a nasty when
you pass me yeah
so
yeah i don't know man i feel like it's
it's almost um it's almost more widely
accepted in my mind through music
uh chance you know i'm saying like all
these artists like used to be open
so in my head i'm like okay well kanye
does jesus is king and it's probably his
least
successful album ever yeah by the way
what did you think of that jesus king
yeah so when i first heard it i was like
ah it's cool and then i went and i
i played it and i started talking
everybody around breakfast i was like
yeah but this part was dope the
production was hard
on it the missed part was dope but the
opening vocals on this and then i was
like wait
nah this project's dope right so once i
started breaking down all the things i
liked about i was like you know what at
the end of the day i'm just a kanye stan
me too of everything
and
no matter what it's always going to be a
little left of center he's going to do
something different he's going to push
the envelopes and do cool production and
i'm like i'm a fan so i'm just here
kanye is my favorite artist ever now is
my favorite rapper
but kanye to me okay yeah that makes
sense best discography ever that makes
sense
he always
whatever direction you're going he jerks
the wheel yeah yeah and sends you on a
ride what's your favorite uh kanye album
oh man
probably
probably dark twisted fantasy i mean
that's the that's the one that's just
like
i think that's his best album i think my
favorite's probably late registration
but his best album is dark twisted
fantasy yeah
i like graduation a lot too you know i'm
not as high in graduation as everyone
else i and i like the weird like the
ones off there that people sleep i like
barry bonds i also like um
uh i don't like breathing and breathe
that's his worst song okay um
but you know what you don't have many of
those like drunken hot girls and like
robocop the only like joints in his
discography that i'm like
i could do without those
that's it everything else i'm like these
are good songs i agree
even like now there was something on yay
that i did not like but i think ghost
town is one of the best kanye songs ever
so i just cried the ghost town just the
fact that ghost town's on yay puts it
and kid see ghost to me might be a top
five kanye project ever really kissy
ghost is so [ __ ] perfect to me let's
see ghost is fire i'll take kitsy ghost
over watch your throne every day of the
week
no questions i'm sorry
i will take kids see ghosts over watch
the throne
1 000 you're sick no not a chance bro
i'm not doing that i'm not gonna let
that slide man
personally for me i just think kids i
think watch the throne has some some low
points
i was not a fan of of of the first
record the it was a lift off oh with
beyonce i wasn't crazy about that bro we
this ain't live right i can take a piss
yeah go take a piss go take get your
piss on buddy all right we're we're back
like 10 minutes he was saying before
that yeah we know we were just talking
about how watch the throne is an
inferior album to kitsy ghost you're
psychotic
just no church in the wild alone oh no
it's amazing yeah
did you go to the wash the throne tour
no i went to
[Music]
what i do
jesus jesus tour is crazy with the
mountain the mountain yeah so i did that
i saw life of pablo
um that's the only kanye tour i didn't
go to because he ended up canceling the
date i was supposed to go i was going to
fly to denver to see him but he had that
meltdown and then canceled the rest of
the tour i was like looking forward to
like standing under
man it was you know so dope about that
kanye show was
he's he's part of the show but then
watching everyone else
underneath them dancing and going crazy
that's like part of the show too so it's
an inception performance because you
don't know what to watch like the people
watching him is is part of it so
yeah
um
you this new video you you sent me the
link for i watched it uh yesterday uh
first of all great idea thanks man
recreating all the hip classic hip hop
covers yeah you caught all of them i
caught every single one single one yeah
public enemy run dmc capital punishment
dmx 50 all eyes on me kanye
there's some others i'm missing nwm nwa
wayne yeah carter carter wasn't mad
villainy
yeah that's you know what i wanted to do
i wanted to set that up in a way so like
you know you could do like uh
you get like the time frame of when it
pops up to guess what it is and see what
people scored no i was amazing i got it
i was a thousand percent for sure um
but incredible video um your visuals in
general are always very very uh on point
like is that you is that your directors
yeah
um
it's me uh dell dell just mustafa he's
part of my my creative team
um and then i just got a handful of
people that we we use so shout out dust
brand films he did that video he's a hip
hop head so he was like the perfect dude
to do it um
but yeah you know it's like i don't have
just like one person i create
all my videos with it's kind of like
you know we pulling it together
depending on that video is crazy man and
it was like flawlessly executed thank
you all those were done in camera so
there was very little post effects so
every time it would pan into something
it'd be a physical set that was built
wow so you know like even on mad
villainy like that's the real mess and
behind you you know there's that little
square in the corner that's red
that was just posit like a red piece of
square uh posted up in the back to make
it look like the album so how hard was
it to pull off the uh
the uh eminem show [ __ ] like did you
have to find a red curtain somewhere
yeah so we went to like a middle school
and they let us use their auditorium and
then there was a red curtain and uh we
had to use their spotlight and line
everything up and then put little gold
um leafing across the bottom of the the
uh curtain to make it look like that
cover so
now you know how it was like an hour of
just like
slide back an inch go to the left you
know and but we were trying to make them
as exact as possible
uh your album just came out uh
the tours is oh it's almost over right
yeah we got like four more dates so it's
we got the fonda tonight we got uh
san francisco then we got denver so
that's it that is i feel like short run
denver's everyone's best concert market
for some reason i don't know what it is
about denver denver [ __ ] love
to go to concerts in denver i don't know
what it is there's people who sell out
the red rocks that won't do a thousand
tickets in l.a that's right but they
sell out the [ __ ] red rocks bro i i
sell out denver every time i play there
just fanatics there i always say
denver's like probably the best concert
like as far as like people going and
spending money on live shows yes every
artist i've ever talked to they're like
yo denver denver denver denver i think
denver might be the the highest selling
show on this whole tour helen
yeah denver's a movie shout out denver
shot i can't breathe when i'm there but
high altitude fantasy are you a smoker
nah no smoking no i get anxiety
i like panic attacks just it's bad you
never want you partake in any
psychedelics or anything are you just
pretty straight-edged god man you know
what it is i just like my life
that's fair i just like i'm just being
sober is so dope to me that i'm like
it's like shit's going great for me yo
just things are dope i don't ever feel
the need to be like you know what i
really want to get incoherent right now
like nothing
you know i go to therapy too so
i'd be dealing with my
demons and i think some of that gives me
that like yo i just want to drink water
and go for a jog that's what i'm saying
i'm no good for tv bro
i'll just be i'd be upset i'm like i
want to i want to work out and eat
healthy you don't say i'm like what's
your diet like it's pretty was it are
you you know we try to we out here
trying to live right trying to live
righteous but but you know from time to
time uh we do partake in the fried
chicken uh what are you gonna do you got
i mean you're italian right so like
italian food is
amazing yeah but it's also probably the
worst food for you because it's just
that's the pasta i'm a foodie though
basically the way that i i calculate my
day is like all right if i go work out
then i can have this nonsense at night
you know what i'm saying so i basically
i just be trying to budget you're just
kind of like yo if i can just have a
wash every day that's it if i could just
break even
good that's it so you know we just
trying to eat whatever there's real good
food and i'm not um picky i'll try
i'll try something you know what i'm
saying something new you ever had
rattlesnake
i haven't i haven't had rousseau but i
would try it 100 have you yeah in
arizona that's like normal yeah i mean
it's like it's not normal it's not like
you go to [ __ ] every there's like
rattlesnake tuesdays that y'all just
have that but i've had it
it's not bad rattlesnake's not bad
alligator's fire
i just had some gator in florida the
gator 100
i had some kangaroo in australia
wow not dope not good don't do it i
wouldn't do it either yeah i mean i did
it just but it's not like kangaroos are
too cute to eat what's the joint out
here i gotta hit in la i don't even know
man i'm not yeah just be in and out and
all the time that's it nah um
dave's hot chicken is like basic [ __ ]
[ __ ] like there's a dave's hot chicken
up the street like go go get a hot
chicken sandwich it's [ __ ] amazing
amazing
amazing
the main like place everyone goes to
nobu
no that's awesome
porto's in burbank is the highest rated
restaurant on yelp at least it was for a
really time
and then there's another place called
the morrison
that is top 10 rated uh burger in the
country really the morrison porto's is a
bakery pet pastries desserts and cuban
food
it's like two minutes from here it's
smacking
100 percent that like literally on my ig
every city i pop in so i'm like yo i'm
in your city what's the food
recommendations and i you know
that's it man we went to japan last uh
right before the pandemic did a ramen
tour i mean yeah ramen's the best we out
here walling for food there it is man
well listen i appreciate you pulling up
my brother appreciate you yes sir man
get some dave's hot after this some
dave's hot